I thought Nightcrawler was a great movie
it also made me feel like a terrible
person let's get started
I'll talk to people about Nightcrawler
most people focus on blue Blume they
talk about how sleazy and gross he is
and how well Jake Gyllenhaal pays off
his performance is true blue is
thoroughly creepy his associate path who
from the beginning we see is the bad guy
an antihero who selfishly does what he
sees as necessary to get ahead and make
a profit I'm looking for a job and so
when he sees the opportunity to start up
a news gathering service he jumps on it
must be on television warning news if it
bleeds it leads
what channel whoever pays the most but
here's my question is Lou the only
villain Nightcrawler
I mean of course he's an awful guy who
does some awful things in the movie but
why you pursue something is equally as
important as what your pursue here you
go Lou does what he does because the
people who are paying him are asking for
it we should have packages like this
every day I don't really care how he got
it they just cared that he gets it and
gets it first and gets it
well graphic isn't it the media's
demands that drives Lou to become a
predator feeding off of other people's
sufferings for a profit so we can shift
some of the blame to the media
but aren't they just like Lou simply
willing to do what it takes to get ahead
they do what they do because the people
who are paying them are asking for it
the viewers don't really care how the
media got it they just care that they
get it and get it first and get it
bloody the media produces what it does
because it's driven by the ratings and
the ratings are driven by you the
viewers I don't think it's any secret
that I've single-handedly raised the
unit price or your ratings book so when
you look at Lou and you feel disgusted
the movie points a finger back at you
you the viewer ask to see what Lou and
the media produce it doesn't absolve Lou
bloom in the media of their wrongs of
course but you can't ignore that you're
at least complicit in the process as
what's shown in Nightcrawler becomes
more and more graphic we the viewers
leaned in
the same curiosity that causes Lou to
stop at the car accident that inspires
him to pursue his career in the first
place I think a lot of people miss this
theme in Nightcrawler because while
they're watching they might think well I
don't watch 24-hour news and they
imagine they're not part of the problem
but Nightcrawler doesn't let you off so
easily I think it clearly insinuates
that Hollywood and movies like itself
are in fact part of the problem let me
show you what I mean in the beginning we
are simply observers of Lou's
wrongdoings we see him attack the guard
from a distance while a train passes
blocking out the sound as things
progress we continue to watch Lou
capture footage of horrific events but
the film focuses on him instead of what
he's capturing and when we do see what
he's capturing its amateurish and very
different from what we're seeing from
the film's perspective but as we go into
the third act Lou's camera work becomes
more cinematic what he's capturing on
his cameras grows to fill our screens we
see things from the point of view of
what he's filming and what he films
looks like what we're seeing in the rest
of the movie the central action of what
he films becomes the action of the film
were watching at the very climax of the
action the perspective of Lou's camera
and the perspective of the film merge
into one and what we see as a shot a
movie becomes the footage Lou is selling
to the TV station
here Nightcrawler is essentially
pointing out that as the viewer while
watching this movie for the same reasons
people want to see what Lou is filming
and selling to the news we partake of
this display of violence and comfort
ourselves that it's fake it's just a
movie but Lou escapes the law walks out
of the police station and under the
Hollywood sign in the distance in the
same way that we escape the blame under
the label of entertainment but
Nightcrawler says were all complicit and
the wrongs along the way I recently
asked a friend of mine if he had seen
Nightcrawler and he said he had turned
it off because it was too disturbing and
I think at least according to
Nightcrawler that's the only way you can
avoid blame
I'm Thomas flight and this has been a
video for my series off the screen a
series of videos that takes a closer
look at the media we consume you got
something out of this video I'd really
appreciate it if you left a comment or
share it with someone who uses might
enjoy it
thanks again for watching and